so i've already outlined to you how
donald trump
owes not 300 million dollars not 420
million dollars but likely trump's total
debts are about 1.1 billion dollars to
various creditors
and i've already outlined in the
previous segment how this makes trump a
national security risk
there's another piece to this and that
additional element is that donald
trump's businesses are just failing
right now
donald trump's entire resort business is
collapsing partially
due to his own mishandling of
coronavirus and it actually goes even
further
trump's own desperation to open the
economy
could well be motivated by the desire to
rehabilitate
his own businesses what's increasingly
clear
is that were it not for donald trump's
reality show host career on the
apprentice
he might be totally insolvent because
his resorts are
true money pits trump actually used a
bunch of his apprentice money
to go and buy golf courses and resorts
around the world and they're all doing
terribly
of the 15 golf resorts that trump bought
as of 2015
almost none are profitable trump bought
doral
it looks like doral i guess he
pronounces it doral for 150 million
it's lost 162 million since his resorts
in scotland have lost
63 million that much bandied about hotel
in washington dc
near the white house has lost more than
55 million dollars
between 2008 and 2009 the trump
organization
lost 1.4 billion dollars as his tax
documents show
and none of those numbers account for
2019 and 2020
and what's going on with coronavirus and
and by the way
trump alienating half the country
through his presidency
has not helped his business half the
country now
would not go to his resorts on principle
because he's a failed moronic president
he's damaged his brand
and his reputation through his
presidency
and then in comes coronavirus and it's a
disaster
partially because trump himself was slow
to deal with coronavirus
trump being slow to take coronavirus
seriously
has hurt trump's own businesses and this
gets us to why trump behaves the way he
behaves
why is trump dragging his entire
presidential entourage
with secret service to his own resorts
week after week after week
to funnel money into his failing resorts
why is trump desperate
to open hotels and the economy even when
it's too early during coronavirus
because he needs his resorts open
because they are failing
all of these stories connect golfing at
his own resorts all the time
demanding the economy open desperation
to win re-election no matter what
hiding his taxes through any means he
can allegedly laundering money through
the campaign
there is a grand narrative here and it's
that trump is failing financially
personally maybe at risk of personal
bankruptcy
and he's desperate to stave it off now
one last thing
the big takeaway from all of these
financial revelations this week
should not be trump is a fake
billionaire there are too many people
focusing on that people on the left and
the right
the real takeaways here are systemic the
system
allowed a lunatic sycophant to become
president on the false notion
of being a successful businessman and
the electoral college helped him
despite losing the popular vote that's a
systemic issue
the system allows the rich people who
are super rich at least on paper like
trump
to pay no taxes through various
mechanisms including
tax loss carry forwards and asset
depreciation
which i went over with you yesterday the
system
allows a president to funnel money into
their own businesses
with no repercussions trump has said
he'd be great for the middle class and
people should pay taxes
and he's been terrible for the middle
class and he doesn't pay taxes so the
story is not fake billionaire
the story is all of these other things
which we should focus on
38 days from now after the election but
between now and then the election is the
focus
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience 20
off lucy is a company founded by caltech
scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical